u.s stocks are having their worst start
to a year in nearly a century at the
same time inflation is rising at the
fastest pace in around 40 years in times
like these folks are looking for places
to put their money where they won't lose
it but can also see some gains with that
in mind i want to tell you about one
long spurned asset that has recently
become a favorite among top wall street
money managers
cash
i'm going to tell you why some on wall
street are holding cash right now
instead of buying the dip how we're
seeing this trend play out and i'll tell
you about some investments that wall
street pros are using to earn a little
return on their cash
let's get into it
i'm hearing it more and more from the
professional money managers i talked to
the increased volatility and uncertainty
that we're seeing in markets is expected
to continue that's due to the ongoing
war in ukraine disrupted supply chains
and central banks raising rates to fight
inflation we've been living in a low
inflation world for more than a decade
and it looks like we're entering a new
regime
when things change it can take a while
before it becomes clear what the winners
and losers will be that's why some of
the world's largest asset managers say
they're happy to have their money in
cold hard cash these days as opposed to
buying the dip directors at
multi-trillion dollar asset managers
like blackrock and state street so they
have increased the cash holdings in many
of their portfolios by at least 50
percent gaurav malik chief investment
strategist at state street global
advisors tells me cash is king right now
in terms of the return you're getting
bank of america's latest survey of
global asset managers found that putting
money in cash was the most popular
investment strategy
but major money managers aren't burying
their dollars in the backyard and
getting zero percent they're holding
cash like assets
and those are paying higher rates than
they have in years now that the federal
reserve has raised u.s overnight
interest rates to at least 0.75 percent
some money market funds are paying 0.8
annual interest asset managers say they
also like short duration treasury bills
which mature between one and three
months those are backed by the us
government and are currently paying
between 0.5 and 1 annual interest
everyday investors can buy those
straight from the government through
treasurydirect.gov or through brokerages
and speak in a treasury direct
every u.s citizen can buy series i
savings bonds which are paying 9.6
annual interest right now for all the
details on i bonds check out my video
from early april the link is in the
description
certainly earning one percent interest
or less
isn't all that exciting but if the
federal reserve keeps raising interest
rates the way they've predicted cash
like investments could return two or
even three percent by the end of the
year and with the s p 500 off to its
worst start since 1932
two or three percent isn't half bad the
late slauson avenue legend nipsey hustle
blessed us with some wisdom he said now
it's up to you are you gonna take heed
and get paid and scream all money in
until your dying day say forget the
middleman get on your grind and save
or are you more the type to have your
mind enslaved
that's all for now see you next time